yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing the fair term here with flick
okay so we gotta ruin or passes Blackie
and this line is something that I've
tried tried out a bit in recent times
with mixed results i have to say some
games were good but in some games I
definitely have trouble so it's not
exchanging on d 7 my idea is a quick f5
I'm not going to be subtle here maybe
this is too weak aligned I don't know
but ever i think it's interesting at
least night BTW to hasn't really helped
him in regards of the deep on yeah i
mean taking d5 now is probably risky or
is it not I mean it's a big part it's a
big center pond so I'm grabbing this Oh
f5 left 93 okay I'm kind of making
things up yes as I go along it's not a
way to do it so maybe maybe I shouldn't
have taken but I mean I'm willing to do
some things form for a center porn okay
so he wants to play 96 it seems okay
well it's that's not the end of the
world
[Music]
I can try here to cancel long actually
not that I have to but it's something
that that might be might be possible
very uncommon in some in some Spanish
lines but it could work I mean now it's
over with castling short at least we
know about that so queen to d6 and
canceling long that's my plan I know it
looks decent looks like a decent plan
it's my position shaky somewhat yeah it
is but how can he actually benefit I
move like night to age for doesn't take
a fire but I cook Queen d7 so Queenie
tool what's the big deal I don't know it
I don't know I just developed now and go
go along this is also hinting at naija
form that that could be could be useful
[Music]
whoa I actually always thought Quincy
five would be good but I here actually
he's got a check it's got a check coming
up I can also check first on c5 I don't
know if this is actually helping me
[Music]
other other way other squares 97 for
something simple but Bishop f4 is kind
of annoying I can also try an IG for I
don't know if this helps in any way this
is actually interesting let's do it I
mean that's a funny funny way of playing
this but it's interesting g 3 i'm going
to play night to you three it's a bit of
a shocker
Bishop takes Knight excrete takes bishop
t four winds that wins the Queen so I
was he's going for this that looks like
the set work actually I can check on d4
now I can also just play Bishop b5
there's nothing wrong with that I think
I have the check here also as a backup
so I have this check all right let's
just let's just bring this King out of
the middle it looks excellent anyway
pretty much regardless of what I'm doing
so check why not check let's check c4 is
hanging am I just taking this pawn I can
also take first on III yeah this is
actually good on ya this is very good
and Bishop g4 at the end
let's think pretty good technically very
dominating with the rukon the second end
is down how much two pawns yeah and I
can just probably just go up with a king
to e5 quite resigned yeah it's very very
one-sided yeah that that went well yeah
but he gave away d 5 I don't know maybe
it was there was some tactics in the
beginning because my position dr. Ted
Ted lose so here yeah I don't know it
looks very weekend what what he has here
nine f6c forgiven by the engineer you
probably want to protect it I mean he
has no its development is pretty awful
so probably this is good for me I mean
even if or seems good luck according to
the engine yeah I wonder yeah I mean if
anything has to take care and then try
to do some tactic here yeah it probably
has some tactic i mean i have this and
as i said but check oops and i have to
do something crazy now 26 I mean the
engine says I'm slightly better but then
that wasn't intended I mean nothing of
it so probably I should have thought for
a moment here this is just stronger
right of the c-4 I probably can can play
some B 5 or I mean this is this is good
anywhere with
having enormous space advantage the
computer just want to play wants to play
this position ask white what those
nights are doing this structure wouldn't
be all that bad if whites nights were
some somewhere here but they are
completely misplaced and that was the
wise decision they have it the way it
went he didn't didn't didn't get
anywhere this is just good for black
young I'm kind of making all the NGOs
that's nice and here takes the check
yeah I should have checked him right and
be sure takes you four and saw that that
that too late but check the position is
so bad this is really check not really
all that all that important i had i
chose a technical way but you could have
taken taken away more material yeah ok
guys thanks for watching
[Music]